[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en janvier dernier j'ai fait partie
d'une croisière avec 350 personnes bonne
croisière dans sud une croisière au
québec en plein hiver une journée on est
resté pris sur le fleuve parce qu'ils
faisaient une tempête les ressources est
pas dramatique
en fait ça ressemble plus à un partez
avec des amis une journée de congé
d'école et c'est peut-être là cet
événement imprévu me permis de tester la
théorie sur les nanos influenceurs je
suis un danois un français revisitent
peut-être du nano influenceurs sans
savoir je faisais partie de cette grande
expédition là en tant que responsable
des médias sociaux
mon expérience m'a permis de voir que
les noms et france heures pouvait
changer
l'algorithme de facebook
on partait de gaspé sur un bateau de
croisière pour se rendre à montréal en
passant par le bas saint laurent la part
charlevoix et par québec dans mon
domaine il ya différentes écoles de
pensée personnellement je fais partie de
ceux qu'on appelle les teams organique
c'est à dire les gens qui croient que
les bonnes stratégies doivent être
fortes sans devoir payer de publicité ou
avant deux pays de la publicité
il ya d'autres gens dans mon domaine qui
croit que toute bonne stratégie doit
inclure absolument un budget
publicitaire dans notre domaine
on parle aussi souvent des influenceurs
part accrue doucement qui ici a déjà
entendu ce terme là influenceurs êtes
des connaisseurs à bord du navire on
avait des influenceurs
c'est à dire que ce sont des
personnalités qui accepte d'endosser des
marques des causes des entreprises qui
grâce à leur notoriété vont bien
paraître ces compagnies là on avait
entre autres une astronaute
on avait un joueur de football américain
on avait une championne olympique et
plusieurs pays
finalité de la télé on avait aussi ce
qu'on appelle des micros influenceurs
c'est à dire des blogueurs plein air
tourisme voyages on avait plusieurs
artistes en résidence
soit des arts visuels ou encore des
artistes de la scène et on avait ce que
moi j'appelle les nanos influenceurs
c'est à dire des dizaines et des
dizaines d'amateurs de ski de fond et de
raquette qui étaient inscrits pour
explorer nos paysages gaspésiens et
québécois une journée quand on est parti
un soir quand on est parti de matane
pour se rendre à pointaux paix qui a une
superbe tempête de neige québécois s'est
levé à bord du bateau c'était l'euphorie
tout le monde sur les ponts a senti les
balles de neige à danser à chanter le
gros party
le lendemain matin en principe on devait
être à point topic
j'ai regardé mon téléphone pour voir
leur pillay avait un message d'une
collègue qui devait et on pourra pas
accoster avant plusieurs heures
est ce que ton offre d'ateliers sur les
réseaux sociaux type peugeot on
l'attendrait oh oui je me suis souvenu
qu avant qu'on parte de gaspé
l'organisation avait demandé aux gens à
bord alors à l'équipe dans le fond puis
aussi aux personnalités de prévoir des
activités encore d'intempéries encore
who lives artistes one piece postiers
c'était cette journée là j'ai donc donné
un atelier sur les réseaux sociaux dans
mon atelier entre autres parlé de
l'algorithme de facebook
l'algorithme de facebook c'est un peu
comme essayer de percer le secret de la
fameuse bourde chocolat c'est un peu les
personnes qui connaît absolument tous
les facteurs mais on en connaît au moins
de 5
cette journée là je me suis attardé à
trois facteurs le premier facteur c'est
l'intérêt l'intérêt c'est un peu comme
le slogan dans mon enfance puis elles
sont fraîches puis on en mange plus on
en mange plus et sont fraîches
est ce que certains se souviennent de ça
c'était les saucisses hygrade l'intérêt
pour facebook mal algues rire c'est que
plus
vous allez interagir avec certaines
personnes ou certaines pages plus vous
allez voir les publications de ces
personnes là où ces pages là dans votre
fil d'actualité si vous interdisez de
moins en moins avec certaines personnes
ou certaines pages vous verrez de moins
en moins leurs publications voire plus
du tout les autres facteurs de
l'algorithme sont un peu plus complexes
à comprendre et à expliquer au fil des
années j'ai développé la métaphore du
poêle à bois pour m'aider à les
illustrer dans la métaphore je compare
le rapport entre le type de publication
et l'engagement des abonnés 1 1 point là
bois donc à du combustible jeu une
publication texte fait qu'il faut un
brûler du papier journal
donc ce produit pour beaucoup de chaleur
pour beaucoup d'engagement une
publication de liens déjà on a plus
d'interactions donc se produit un peu
plus de chaleur un peu plus d'engagement
ce qui vaut à une petites bûches de
bouleau une photo on a une bouche derrab
plus de chaleur plus d'engagement une
vidéo
une bonne idée râble ça peut produire
pas mal d'engagement une vidéo pour
qu'un feu reprenne
on a aussi besoin d'air si les pages
contrôler le type de publications
qu'elle propose à nos abonnés ce sont
les abonnés qui contrôlent l'engagement
par leurs interactions
donc ce sont eux qui alimente le feu en
l'air
si un abonné qui viennent ou une
réaction
art a surpris importe c'est comme s'ils
donnaient un peu d'air offre une petite
partie de ses amis vont voir que tel a
mis à aimer telle publication de tel
autre nid où de telles pages si
quelqu'un commet une publication plus de
ses amis vont voir que une interaction
donc le plus de valeur c'est comme plus
d'air ça va donner une portée organique
supérieure quand quelqu'un partagent une
publication plus de ses amis le voient
plus de ses amis peuvent interagir à
leurs taux on a beaucoup
plus d'air est beaucoup plus de porter
le dernier facteur de l'algorithme de
facebook c'est leur récent la récence
c'est une combinaison de deux choses la
première c'est le temps de publication
le moment où les la page
au fait la publication et les récentes
la deuxième aspect c'est le temps de
réaction plus les gens interagissent
servir avec une publication plus elle
est susceptible de devenir virale dans
toutes les activités qui étaient
proposés cette journée-là sur le bateau
l'une des filles de l'organisation m'a
été samuel leduc a eu l'idée d'organiser
un mannequin challenge est ce qu'ils
connaissent aussi mannequin chez aline
c'est un peu comme quand on est enfant
qu'on jouait à statut sauf que là c'est
filmé on va regarder un petit bout
assange
[Musique]
step au pire comme vous avez pu voir
tout le monde a embarqué dans la vidéo
même la capitaine personnel vraiment
tout le monde a eu beaucoup de choses et
quand ils l'ont vu le soir la vidéo
montée mais les on espérer qu'on la
publie sur les réseaux sociaux il avait
un d'interagir il avait hâte de la
partager de la montrer aux gens qu'il
connaît sauf que l'on leur a dit non à
tout de suite dans facebook le coût
d'engagement moyen de toutes les pages
est un site pour ça nous cette semaine
la grâce à notre travail on travaille
des gens qui étaient avec nous on a viré
à l'extérieur on a atteint 85 % de taux
d'engagement
si à la maison en plein hiver québécois
ont fait un bon feu
il fait 24 degrés celsius à l'intérieur
est-ce qu'on va s'empresser de mettre
notre si belle bûche d'érable dans le
voit la bourre non on va attendre que ça
refroidisse un peu c'est ce qu'on a fait
avec la vidéo du mannequin challenge
mines semaines après l'événement on
envoyait un message à tous nos membres
pour le redis il faut l'attendre et la
vidéo on la diffuse samedi prochain dans
quatre jours on vous demande d'être
l'ombre la merde à 7 heures le matin
si vous pouviez faire agir le plus
rapidement possible ça nous aiderait
beaucoup on le fait le lundi suivant
on a publié la vidéo on a fait un test
avec les tests à b c'est que en
organique
donc comme d'habitude on a publié la
vidéo directement sur le fil d'actualité
de la page de la tdlg de la grande
traversée de la gaspésie est enlevée on
a payé 200 dollars pour faire une
publication qu'on appelle barque poste
c'est à dire que les abonnés ne voit pas
on a ciblé les gens qui ressemblait nous
abonnés dont comparables en excluant les
abonnés au bout de quatre jours on a
mesuré les résultats on a fait pour la
publication organique a atteint près de
120 mille personnes et pour celle pour
laquelle on avait payé 200 dollars on
avait atteint tout près de 3500
personnes
si on fait une règle de trois même si on
sait que c'est un peu plus
plex que ça on pourrait dire que si on a
dû débourser 200 $ pour rejoindre 3500
personnes il aurait fallu dépenser tout
près de 6000 $ pour rejoindre cent vingt
mille personnes
donc c'est ça la valeur du travail
donnons à nos influences heures pour cet
épisode là en particulier un anneau
influenceurs c'est quoi un ambassadeur
un ambassadeur c'est quelqu'un qui dans
la vraie vie est une marque un produit
une cause un événement et en parlent
autour de lui à ses amis c'est très bien
mais la portée est limitée
l'abonné l'abonné lui il aime une page
mais il interagit pr nécessairement tout
le temps ou s'il le fait c'est pas de
façon nécessairement consciente
le nano influenceurs elite une
combinaison des deux il est à la fois un
abonné il doit être sur les réseaux
sociaux pour être un influenceur ce ne
l'est pas et en plus il a l'attitude de
l'ambassadeur donc le nano influenceurs
et quelqu'un qui sait consciemment qu'à
chaque fois qu'il interagit avec la
publication d'une page i live cette page
pour que les publications soient plus
vues et qu'elles atteignent plus de gens
et que plus de gens en parlent
ce qui est important de savoir c'est que
le nano influenceurs n'est pas une
influence souvent des influenceurs vont
être payés pour parler des marques c'est
pas le code non influencé la non un
français c'est pas quelqu'un qui pour
les compères facebook n'ont vu c'est
quelqu'un qui a vu avec son grand coeur
parce que pour reprendre les mots de
claudine roy la fondatrice de la
sidérurgie
le plus important dans la vie mes amis
c'est l'amour
souvenez-vous de ce peu importe qu'on
soit tim organique ou team publicité on
a tous un objectif commun c'est à dire
qu'on souhaite de la conversion pour la
tdlg la conversion c'était d'espérer que
l'interaction et les interconnexions
entre tout le monde
qui ont élevé pour que nos publications
soient plus vu qu'elles atteignent plus
de gens que plus de gens en parlent et
que finalement plus de gens s'inscrivent
aux éditions suivantes
on l'a atteint c'était notre objectif de
conversion pour la petite épicerie fine
que vous aimez pour le média indépendant
que vous affectionnez particulièrement
pour la boutique au coin de la rue le
taux de conversion
c'est parfois ce qui peut faire la
différence entre survivre fermé plus
prospérer ensemble ici aujourd'hui at
elle dit québec on est comme sur un
navire ensemble si on le veut on peut
influencer les réseaux sociaux je suis
une nana influenceurs vous pouvez être
des mano influençable
merci
[Applaudissements]